of course perhaps the most famous skewer
that you may not even have known was a
skewers the one from searching for bobby
fisher' here you can see that cute
little movie poster but a viewer is
essentially a reverse pin where in the
case of a pin a a piece is unable to
move or doesn't want to move for fear of
losing material and the skewer case the
piece is forced to move and he will lose
whatever material is behind it so one of
the more common ways that skewers occur
actually happens to be in the endgame
because you have these open board
positions with all kinds of open
diagonals and squares so the potential
for files and ranks and diagonals to be
critical in terms of a check or a skewer
is higher the board is more open and a
skewer itself can only be done by a
long-range piece which is a bishop rook
or queen so this position here is is the
end of that brilliant combination where
Josh is like don't move until you Thiet
and Bruce is like he sees it and Josh is
like I offer you a dois and the kids
like what you lost and he's like you're
lost you just don't know it yet and then
he's like he sees it and then Laurence
Fishburne's like he sees what and then
Josh is like don't move until you Thiet
anyway at the end of that combination
this is what you end up seeing on the
board believe it or not Big Town pawn
town race town Queen town skewer town
wind town black King has to move and and
we win and he move earlier by the black
king at any moment
moving the king even first just to try
to anticipate and get off the diagonal
will also not be good enough because now
when white Queens white is guarding the
critical queening square and also easily
winning so a skewer in this specific
skewer along with the next two we're
going to see are probably arguably in
this whole video the three most
important skewers to know whenever
you're evaluating upon race don't take
for granted that at the end of the line
there may be a skewer one other way that
happens could could be something random
like this where you think that Oh both
sides are queening and and I calculated
this long line and I thought both sides
with Queen and now I deserve a draw
because
we have king queen vs king and queen
well the game is not declared a draw
right there and so you must always
consider what the four series of checks
might be after both sides now have
Queens on the board because sometimes
things like this happen so pawns
promoting two queens and either this
immediately brilliant skewer at the end
of searching for bobby fisher' or simply
a four series of checks that might lead
to a skewer is one of the most common
types of skewer tactics we need to know
and so the first theme of the five
themes you see here now with our bullet
list that we're covering is the checking
skewer the skewer where we check a king
and when whatever piece is behind it
the second theme we're going to cover as
far as skewers go is the overloaded
skewer or a piece is overloaded the
third is one where I made up a cool name
myself I like to call it fatal
attraction or awkward attraction skewer
you're like what is that is that a
Sharon Stone movie no just wait you're
going to see it the fourth one is weak
square skewers where we are skewering
pieces not necessarily to other pieces
but to important squares and finally I
call the fifth point the equal value
skewer as you see here which is where we
can see our pieces of equal or even less
value it doesn't always have to be where
you you skewer a piece and win something
brilliant behind it sometimes you can
skewer a piece and win an important pala
these are the five bullet points you see
here now let's move on to a couple more
of these endgame skewer examples to stay
on our theme of the checking skewer
before we move on to theme to the next
perhaps maybe just as famous as the
searching for bobby fisher' skewer the
king and queen skewer is the back door
rook tricks cure if you don't know the
position you can pause here as my
recommended time 30 seconds for masters
one minute for experts two minutes for
1600 and 2000 and three minutes for 1200
to 1600 you shouldn't need too much time
below 1200 you can have five plus
minutes the main theme here and this may
not be the most practical example of the
back door Brook trick and I do want to
emphasize that because it can happen in
a number of different positions and it's
something
you should never turn your turn your
eyes to when it comes to a situation
where you have a pawn on the seventh
ranked whom you would love to promote to
a queen but you're unable to do it
because the regards the pawn moving this
rook to any square that is not a temple
square it's just going to allow me to
take that pawn but we have a backdoor
rook trick here after f6 check taking
the pawn would obviously allow the rook
to move a check and then queen but the
most common move king of seven gets us
to our backdoor skewer our very infamous
tactic that is where we move the rook to
behind the king allowing the pawn to be
taken and then we give check skewering
the king and rook the most important
point here is that this theme of the
rook moving and then delivering a
devastating skewer is something that
occurs often even not just in this sort
of impractical position where almost all
the pieces are off the board although
this could happen in a real game to the
main theme here is just that looking for
an opportunity to move this rook and
giving the backdoor rook check skewer is
something that is almost just as famous
and just as practical as the king and
queen skewers that we saw in the first
example and and the next one we're going
to see here skewers are all about
recognizing pieces on open files
diagonals and ranks and seizing your
opportunity to to create a tactic
especially when they're aqua be places
we saw in some of the fatal attraction
examples so to stay on this last example
and bring up our five bullet points
again remind you of what you've learned
we have the initial skewer the checking
skewer the forced skewer as you would
say the overloaded skewer where it works
because you're skewing a piece that is
overloaded normally they might have a
way to stop it but you recognize that
they don't in this case our third one of
course is the awkward recognition the
fatal attraction skewer will be plain
attraction tactic to bring the piece to
a square that allows the the skewer to
deliver the slam-dunk then of course we
have this weak square skewers where we
don't always have to be winning material
it's really just about getting access to
an attack and finally the equal value
piece skewer all of these are a skewer
and again just like I summarized it in
of forks it's a theme to just leave
with feeling really good about your
recognition of these tactics that's the
point of this video series is to give
you five themes that you should really
know and help your approach but of
course we're breaking them down into
themes that I would say are pretty much
most commonly all skewers would fit into
those five categories just as all five
of the forks and all five of the pins
would probably fit into one of those
categories if you haven't watched the
forks and pins video go ahead and back
up and check those out and I look
forward to seeing all of you again very
very soon when we do the next video in
this series right look how far we've
come it's just like we're journeying and
all you Paul instructure fanatics out
there just calm down we'll get back to
your positional stuff later this is for
the the mass usership most people really
need these tactics and really need to in
grain this stuff so we can then focus on
strategy and feel like we're really
delivering something that the whole
audience can appreciate so anyway good
talk team go follow me on twitter follow
at chess comm on twitter as well and we
will see you around